To get you primed up to answer this question,
let's first discuss a little bit about the instructions as
architecture of a processor. In the instruction set architecture
of a processor, instructions are atomic by definition, or in
other words if you think about Reads and writes
to memory which are usually implemented at loads and stores,
and the instructions have architecture for processor. Those are
atomic instructions, and what that means is, during the execution
of either a load instruction or a store
instruction or also, as you might think about
them, read or write instruction, the memory. The
processor cannot be interrupted. That's important, that that's
the, the definition of an, of an atomic
instruction that the processor is not going to be
in-, interrupted during the execution of an instruction.
Now the question that I'm going to ask you to
think about is, if I have a multi-threaded program And
in that program, there is a process of P 1,
which is modifying a data structure A, and there is
a process of P 2. That is waiting for the modification
by P 1 to be done, and after the modification
is done, it wants to use that structure. Very natural,
to think about situations in which you have this kind
of a producer-consumer relationship. This guy is the producer of data,
this guy is the consumer of data. And
the consumer wants to make sure that the producer
is done producing it before he starts using
it. Quite natural. Now, given that the instructions of
architecture is only read and write atomic instructions,
The question that I'm going to pose to you is,
is it possible to achieve the programmer's intent
that I have embodied in this code snippet here?
And, you know, the the answer is a binary answer,
yes or no. And and if you, if you answer yes,
I would like to see a code snippet that you think
would make this particular code snipet work correctly on a multiprocessor.